[Music]  it's et social study a quick look at  what the stars are posting online Carl  cook is here tonight why hanma go Q  because he's perfect caitla cuoco and  boyfriend Carl cook are going strong the  big bang theory star brought her beau to  set but Kaylee's ex johnny galecki is  smitten kaylee wrote get off my man  becoming no judgment Oh amber rose  flaunts her assets in this not safe for  work ad for the backless and strapless  sneaky vaunt push-up bra and is Selena  Gomez wearing the weekends sweatshirt in  her latest Instagram pic from the studio  fans noticed the weekends comment and  this side by side shot meanwhile Salinas  ex Justin Bieber posts from paradise and  Bette Midler reveals the first image  from the Hello Dolly on Broadway revival  performances kick off today